die grafschaft lincolnshire mitten in
england in norton einem kleinen dorf
leben gary und natascha waterhouse sie
ist nach einer krebsoperation schwer
behindert er hat seinen job als
taxifahrer aufgegeben um sie zu pflegen
gary zeigt uns ihre gas und
stromrechnungen die kosten sind von
umgerechnet 36 euro im monat auf über
200 euro gestiegen und im herbst und
winter kommen weitere erhöhungen
so major hier überlegen welche räume wir
überhaupt noch heizen können wir werden
mehrere schichten kleidung anziehen und
decken bereithalten um uns zu wärmen
vom staat werden sie eine einmalzahlung
von umgerechnet rund 1200 euro bekommen
doch das wird nicht reichen auch beim
einkaufen müssen sie jetzt sparen gehen
nur noch zum discounter
die preise sind astronomisch gestiegenen
wir kaufen bewusster ein ich koche jetzt
viel vor und habe schon mal zeiten für
die nächsten wochen im gefrierschrank
die inflation in großbritannien ist so
hoch wie seit 40 jahren nicht mehr über
zehn prozent fettarme milch kostet zb 34
prozent mehr als vergangenes jahr die
energiekosten werden sich verdreifachen
oder vervierfachen hunderttausenden
droht der soziale abstieg
um diesen menschen zu helfen hat william
etwaigen eine tafel gegründet heute
kommen noch mehr bedürftige als während
der korona krise sagt er arbeitslose
arbeiter selbstständige die sich ein
paar dosen spaghetti oder bohnen abholen
wollen
[Musik]
manchmal haben wir aber einfach nicht
genügend lebensmittel dann müssen wir
die familien ohne essen nach hause
schicken
wenn eine mutter oder ein vater nicht
genug hat um abendessen zu kochen
dann bricht mir das herz
natürlich nimmt mich dass mit das ist
hart
roland ist krank kann deshalb nicht mehr
arbeiten er weiß nicht wie er seine
familie ernähren soll
das ist wie eine achterbahnfahrt ich
habe einen sohn und eine frau es ist
gerade sehr schwierig zu überleben
die größte angst haben sie vor dem
winter wenn sie ihre heizungen wieder
anstellen müssen
das ist sehr beängstigend weil ich nicht
weiß woher das geld kommen soll um zu
heizen und um essen zu kaufen dann muss
ich mich entscheiden essen oder heizen
das wird sehr hart für uns
wir versuchen einfach wie menschen zu
leben
die ärmsten trifft die krise am
härtesten doch sie hat längst auch die
mittelschicht erreicht wir fahren in den
norden englands in der nähe von york
leben susanna und dave morgen mit ihren
zwei töchtern ihre stromrechnung hat
sich verdreifacht und der liter super
kostet umgerechnet zwei euro 10 die
familie muss sparen auch bei den
freizeitaktivitäten ihrer kinder
[Musik]
wir leben hier auf dem land wir müssen
immer fahren wenn die kinder zum
schwimmkurs wollen müssen wir den kurs
und den sprit bezahlen um dahin zu
kommen
von zu hause aus betreibt das ehepaar
ein online abo service für hochwertigen
kaffee und fürchtet umsatzeinbußen
in der krise denkt jeder darüber nach
wofür man geld ausgibt wir verkaufen
luxusgüter und vielleicht sagen die
leute dann wir kaufen keinen kaffee mehr
balakow
gleichzeitig sind weltweit die
kaffeepreise gestiegen susanna verkauft
eine box mit 500 gramm bohnen jetzt
nicht mehr für 17 sondern für neun cent
wir haben unsere preise erhöht wir haben
aber auch die löhne für unsere
angestellten erhöht weil auch sie ihr
benzin ihren strom und ihre mieten
zahlen müssen
doch viele andere unternehmen scheuen
lohnerhöhungen in der krise dagegen
protestieren arbeiter im ganzen land
london ein club im stadtteil battersea
gewerkschaften und linke verbände haben
zur protestveranstaltung eingeladen
gemeinsam wollen sie für eine faire
bezahlung kämpfen ihre botschaft enough
is enough zu deutsch es reicht
wir gründen eine neue bewegung denn die
leute sind wütend die
lebenshaltungskosten schießen nach oben
und die politiker tun nichts dagegen
mein lohn erhöht sich nicht so stapel
die preise ich bekomme 3 prozent mehr
die inflation liegt bei zehn prozent
deshalb rufen wir die leute dazu auf
ihre energiekosten nicht zu zahlen
mehr als 113.000 briten haben sich
dieser kampagne bereits angeschlossen
wollen widerstand leisten gegen
großunternehmen und politik erhält ist
mit lynch seine eisenbahnergewerkschaft
hat mit streiks gerade das halbe land
lahmgelegt
[Applaus]
die arbeiterklasse ist zurück wir sind
zurück als eine bewegung als eine neue
kraft wir wollen nicht mehr arm sein wir
wollen dass niemand mehr arm ist
sieg der arbeiterklasse
während die arbeiter aufbegehren in der
größten energie krise seit jahrzehnten
ist das land führungslos die alte
regierung trifft keine entscheidung mehr
premierminister boris johnson entspannte
vergangene woche in griechenland heute
tauchte er überraschend in kiew auf traf
sich mit präsident selensky
seine konservative partei sucht derweil
einen nachfolger im duell liegt die
neoliberale außenministerin lesters
deutlich vor ex-finanzminister ritchies
um nach knapp zwei wochen wird der
machtkampf noch dauern
natascha und gary waterhouse haben immer
die konservativen unterstützt doch jetzt
sind sie tief enttäuscht
ihnen geht es nur darum wer neuer
premierminister wird sie haben den bezug
zu den einfachen menschen und zum
mittelstand verloren zu den menschen die
jetzt in der krise leiden
wir fühlen uns wie auf einem sinkenden
verlassenen schiff es ist gerade niemand
am ruder der es in die richtige richtung
steuert sie zanken sich nur und
konzentrieren sich nicht auf die
wichtigen dinge und das sind die
menschen dieses landes
menschen wie natascha und gary und
hunderttausende andere in großbritannien
die nicht wissen wie sie durch den
winter kommen sollen
[Musik]